>>> WE'RE FOLLOWING THE MASSIVE
WINTER STORM PUMMELLING THE
UNITED STATES FROM COAST TO
COAST WITH HEAVY SNOW, ICE, AND
EXTREME COLD.
CNN'S BRIAN TODD IS FOLLOWING
THE STORY FOR US.
BRIAN, THIS SEVERE WEATHER IS
WREAKING HAVOC ACROSS THE WEST
AND THE MIDWEST SPECIFICALLY.
AND IT'S NOW MOVING EAST, RIGHT?
>> Reporter: MOVING EAST AND
SEEMINGLY SPARING NO ONE, WOLF.
TODAY ALONE THERE HAVE BEEN MORE
THAN A HUNDRED VEHICLE CRASHES
IN THE STATE OF MINNESOTA
BECAUSE OF THE WEATHER,
ACCORDING TO THE STATE PATROL.
THROUGHOUT THE ROCKIES AND
PLAINS STATES, IT'S HAZARDOUS
FOR ANYONE INCLUDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BE OUT ON THE
ROADS.
IN WYOMING, A STATE TROOPER HAS
TO SCRAMBLE OUT OF THE WAY AS A
RUNAWAY TRUCK ALMOST HITS HIM.
DANGEROUS CONDITIONS ON A SNOWY
ROAD IN TRUCKEE, CALIFORNIA,
CAUSED THIS CAR TO FLIP.
IN FLAGSTAFF, ARIZONA, THE SNOW
WAS SO VIOLENT THAT THIS MAN
TOLD CNN IT LITERALLY KNOCKED
HIM BACKWARD AS HE AND HIS DOG
STRUGGLED TO SEE AND KEEP THEIR
FOOTING.
A SWEEPING MASSIVE STORM SYSTEM
IS PUMMELLING MUCH OF THE
COUNTRY FROM CALIFORNIA TO
MAINE.
MORE THAN 65 MILLION PEOPLE
UNDER WINTER WEATHER ALERTS
ACROSS THE WEST, MIDWEST, AND
NORTHEAST.
THE MINNEAPOLIS/ST. PAUL AREA
COULD GET AROUND 20 INCHES BY
THE TIME IT'S OVER.
IT COULD BE THE MOST SNOW THAT
AREA HAS SEEN IN THREE DECADES.
MINNESOTA'S GOVERNOR DISCUSSED
THE DANGERS THEY PREPARED FOR.
>> THE GOAL IS TO NOT TO HAVE TO
PULL SOMEBODY OFF THE
INTERSTATE, BUT WE'RE PREPARED
TO DO SO IF THAT HAPPENS.
THE GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE READY IF THERE'S POWER
LOSSAGE, BEING ABLE TO KEEP THE
HIGHWAYS AND MOVE EMERGENCY
VEHICLES AS SOON AS WE CAN.
>> Reporter: CONDITIONS SO
SEVERE IN MINNESOTA THAT
AMBULANCES HAVE TO BE SPECIALLY
EQUIPPED.
>> WE HAVE SHOVELS AND SALT AND
SAND.
WE HAVE A FEW SLEDS IF WE NEED
TO USE THEM.
>> Reporter: CALIFORNIA GETTING
HIT WITH SNOW IN PLACES THAT
DON'T OFTEN EXPERIENCE IT.
>> WE ARE GOING TO SEE LOW SNOW
ALL THE WAY FROM THE OREGON
BORDER TO THE MEXICAN BORDER.
>> Reporter: NORTH OF LOS
ANGELES, A LONG STRETCH OF
VEHICLES IS STOPPED ON STATE
ROUTE 58 AS THE HIGHWAY PATROL
WARNS MOTORISTS.
>> WE ARE ASKING EVERYBODY TO
AVOID THE AREA, MAKE ALTERNATE
PLANS, DRIVE A DIFFERENT DAY.
>> Reporter: BUT IN DIFFERENT
AREAS, DIFFERENT IMPACTS.
NEAR SAN JOSE, HIGH WINDS SNAP
TREES, BROUGHT DOWN POWERLINES,
AND CAUSED WIDESPREAD POWER
OUTAGES.
>> THESE OLD VICTORIANS, THE
WOOD IS SO OLD, IF THERE'S A
SPARK THAT THAT'S WHAT REALLY
WORRIES ME.
>> Reporter: HIGH WINDS CAUSED
SO-CALLED BROWNOUT CONDITIONS
AND SEVERAL VEHICLE ACCIDENTS IN
THE TEXAS PANHANDLE.
AND OF COURSE WITH THIS MASSIVE
SYSTEM, MORE THAN 1,500 FLIGHTS
HAVE BEEN CANCELED.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO THE FLIGHT
TRACKING SITE FLIGHT AWARE.
IT SAYS THE AIRPORTS IN
MINNEAPOLIS/ST. PAUL, DETROIT,
AND DENVER ARE GETTING HIT
HARDEST.
>> BRIAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT REPORT.
LET'S GET THE LATEST FORECAST
RIGHT NOW.
CNN'S JENNIFER GRAY IS JOINING
US FROM OUR CNN WEATHER CENTER.
SO WHICH AREAS WILL BE HIT
HARDEST?
>> THE HARDEST, WOLF, IS GOING
TO BE THOSE AREAS IN THE MIDWEST
AS WELL AS SOUTH DAKOTA AND
NORTH DAKOTA WHERE WE HAVE THESE
BLIZZARD WARNINGS IN EFFECT.
YOU CAN SEE ONE IN WYOMING AS
WELL.
BUT THE IMPACTS TO THESE AREAS
WHERE THE BIGGER CITIES ARE
WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
BLINDING CONDITIONS, ROADWAYS
WILL DEFINITELY BE IMPOSSIBLE TO
TRAVEL ON.
AND ALSO THE ICING CONDITIONS
ACROSS PORTIONS OF THESE AREAS
AS WELL.
YOU CAN SEE THESE AREAS SHADED
IN PINK AND PURPLE.
THAT'S THE ONGOING ICE THREAT
RIGHT NOW.
THE SNOW IN WHITE, OF COURSE.
AND MINNEAPOLIS IS IN THIS BIG
TIME.
THIS COULD BE ONE OF THE
SNOWIEST STORMS ON RECORD FOR
THEM AS THAT SNOW CONTINUES TO
COME DOWN ALL THROUGHOUT THE
OVERNIGHT HOURS THROUGH TOMORROW
MORNING.
SO, FOR THE NORTHERN TIER OF THE
COUNTRY, IT IS GOING TO BE ALL
SNOW, ICE, AND FREEZING RAIN.
WE'LL PUT THIS INTO MOTION, AND
YOU CAN SEE REALLY CLEAR